[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité préserver l'eau
par tous les moyens à l'aide
d'applications connectées ou en
réutilisant les ressources de l'aquarium
vos TV et 7 à Limoges nous vous
dévoilerons ces techniques déployées
alors que l'été s'annonce sec partout en
France à 35 ans on est grand la preuve
dans ce journal avec l'anniversaire du
magazine automobile auto plus un
événement symbolique et l'occasion d'en
savoir plus avec Christophe frigo sur
les coulisses de l'hebdomadaire bien
connu des Français ils sont inséparables
depuis leur rencontre il y a six mois
Moselle TV nous racontera aussi dans
cette édition la belle histoire d'amitié
entre Axel un jeune homme sourd et Rio
le chien qui l'accompagne dans son
quotidien et puis en fin de journal la
rédaction de Télé Grenoble nous en dira
un peu plus sur un métier pour le moins
parfumé celui d'obtenteur de rose une
profession ou l'hybridation se met au
service des couleurs
c'est sûrement le sujet d'actualité qui
fera la une de vos journaux cet été la
sécheresse est dans tous les esprits et
inquiète à quelques jours des grandes
vacances déjà plusieurs dizaines de
départements sont placés en vigilance ou
soumis à des restrictions un contexte
qui pousse évidemment chacun à chercher
des solutions pour économiser l'eau
exemple dans les Vosges ou un système
d'irrigation connecté muni d'une
intelligence artificielle vient d'être
créée objectif diviser la consommation
par deux un dispositif actuellement
testé sur un parcours de golf
explication d'Aurélie Colombel et de
Denis Lequin pour rejeter les visions
l'eau une ressource précieuse que des
ingénieurs de la pépinière d'entreprises
de Saint-Dié comptait aider à préserver
grâce à leur invention un système
d'irrigation connecté muni d'une
intelligence artificielle il y a deux
étapes de l'apprentissage de satia on a
commencé à une collègue de données
depuis 2020 donc on a créé notre datac
notre base de données et puis au fur et
à mesure qu'il y a de récoltes de
données grâce à
l'implantation du système chez chez les
clients il y a cette base de données
elle est de plus en plus et davantage
enrichi par des données mais qui sont
plus personnalisées exemple au golf
l'intérêt de ce système c'est que il se
met exactement dans la politique de la
Fédération Française de Golf qui
souhaite une gestion de l'eau
intelligente et une transition
écologique depuis plusieurs années c'est
génial on a de bons résultats et ça
devrait nous permettre encore
d'économiser sur la gestion de l'eau
au-delà des parcours de golf
l'hydrolorat est développé à destination
des terrains de sport et des
agriculteurs il est d'ailleurs
actuellement testé chez un maraîcher
voilà et des idées pour préserver la
ressource en eau il y en a partout en
France à Limoges c'est l'eau de
l'aquarium qui est désormais réutilisé
par les jardiniers de la ville comme
vous le voyez sur ces images de 7 à
Limoges se sont ainsi des dizaines de
mètres cubes d'eau potable qui sont
économisés les précisions recueillies
par Alain Druot
chez moi j'ai un aquarium et l'autre
changement d'eau dans l'aquarium je gèle
jamais je m'en sers pour arroser mon
potager mes plans d'intérieur parce que
c'est une eau qui est très très bonne
elle est chauffée elle est déclarée elle
est remplie de phosphate et de Nitra
donc de d'engrais pour les plantes et
donc j'ai été rencontré la ville de
Limoges en disant écouté nous on change
de l'eau nos poissons d'eau douce
régulièrement c'est à une très précise
tous les jours est-ce que ça vous
intéresserait pas qu'on va faire un test
pour récupérer cette là pour arroser les
parterre de la ville plutôt que
d'utiliser de l'eau de conduite potable
toutes les idées sont bonnes à prendre
donc l'année dernière c'était les
piscines où on nous a dit de l'eau qui
est jeté à l'égout on pourrait la
réutiliser cette année on a fait des
émules avec l'aquarium qui a eu cette
idée là qui nous a dit également nous on
jette de l'eau on pourrait la réutiliser
reste de l'actualité marquée vous le
savez ces dernières semaines par la
hausse des agressions et des menaces à
l'encontre des maires de France dans le
Tarn et Garonne le harcèlement et les
menaces de mort visant un élu ont poussé
comme vous le constatez sur ces images
de nos partenaires de la Dépêche du Midi
et lui et habitants à se rassembler pour
manifester leur soutien à l'édile
réaction au micro de Manon vanoverbecq
ce rassemblement me fait très plaisir
parce que c'est vrai que je vis des
moments très difficiles depuis trois ans
s'auto dernièrement suite à deux vidéos
qui ont été adressées personnellement à
m'attaquer et aujourd'hui que je sois
avec tous ces élus autour de moi pour me
soutenir mais oui c'est très important
pour moi personnellement je le prends
aussi pour la commune et je le prends
aussi pour notre démocratie nous nous
mobilisons les élus pour dire ça suffit
ça suffit on peut ne pas être d'accord
mais en démocratie on peut échanger on
peut s'engueuler mais on doit se
respecter le maire de Montjoie est
agressé par l'extrême droite le maire de
Toulouse par l'extrême gauche donc oui
ça suffit il faut que l'État prenne ses
responsabilités il faut agir voilà et
puis à noter dans le prochain territoire
de France une interview d'Arès Youssef
l'ancien conseiller de la président
ukrainienne et créateur de la Fondation
Gaïa pour l'écologie il sera l'invité
exceptionnelle du prochain numéro
diffusé sur TV5 Monde regardez un
extrait de l'entretien qu'il à Tom
Benoît le directeur de la rédaction de
géostratégie magazine
ukrainien est-ce que vous avez été
influencé par le soviétisme et par le
régime politique communiste
je faisais partie du monde des affaires
j'étais dans l'économie et je comprenais
et ressentez les processus économiques
ce que j'ai découvert dès le début et
qui m'a surpris c'est le pourquoi
l'énergie n'a-t-elle pas sa définition
un économie pourquoi l'énergie est-elle
un produit à vendre alors que c'est la
matière qui fait toute avancer
entre are Youcef et Tom Benoît sera à
découvrir sur TV5 Monde aussi dès à
présent vous pouvez lire le dernier
ouvrage d'arrêt Youcef publié chez MBU
édition un pamphlet à propos des rouages
du système financier et de l'énergie
tout à fait autre chose protéger le
milieu marin en contribuant à sa
dépollution grâce à la collecte de
déchets ou d'engins de pêche abandonnés
c'est l'objectif de la BIM en Martinique
la brigade d'intervention maritime c'est
son nom créé en 2017 avis à l'aide de
signalement et peut s'appuyer notamment
sur l'engagement de plongeur bénévoles
je remarque quarteron pour via TV a
suivi l'une de ces interventions
regardez
dernière vérification le filet abandonné
est solidement arrimé au cordage
avant de le remonter à banc l'effort est
collectif dans les mailles un petit
poulpe chakram et un hippocampe ont pu
être remis à l'eau aujourd'hui on a
récupéré pas mal de fun dans le filet de
Flore aussi notamment parce qu'il est
imposé sur un herbier le filet c'est
tout le temps le choc de voir à quel
point en fait la biodiversité marine
peut être impactée par les déchets une
véritable opération de sauvetage quand
on sait qu'un filet à l'abandon peut
être mortel pour de nombreuses espèces
les filaments comme ça ça va vraiment
amasser énormément de biomasse parce
qu'en fait ça va faire un peu comme
l'équivalent d'un récif les poissons
vouloir s'agréger autour sauf que
souvent ils vont se prendre dans le
filet sans mêler et finir par mourir et
ça va être aussi plein plein d'autres
types de vie qu'on va trouver dedans
donc soit des coquillages crustacés
mollusques on a pu retrouver des poulpes
notamment une opération menée avec les
plongeurs du club militaire depuis qu'il
est à la retraite Olivier participe
activement au nettoyage des fonds marins
un engagement naturel selon lui donc
plongeur on est bien content d'avoir ce
genre d'association pour nous aider à
évoluer dans un milieu plus propre même
si on sait que ça reste une petite
goutte d'eau on en a encore quelques
quelques kilomètres de filet à retirer
mais bon c'est déjà pas mal après
l'armée s'implique aussi au sein de ce
genre d'opération pourquoi pas tout
simplement parce que
on se doit de participer et au sauvetage
de la vie naturelle de notre île
l'abrigade d'intervention maritime
s'engage pour la dépollution des fonds
marins de la Martinique en deux mois 23
gros déchets et engins de pêche perdu
ont été signalés
et ils sont aussi l'un des symboles
d'une biodiversité menacée par les
activités humaines les hérissons sont
souvent les victimes malheureuses des
voitures des activités de jardinage ou
autre clôtures une réalité mortelle pour
eux contre laquelle des citoyens ont
décidé de se mobiliser en Bretagne entre
soins et sensibilisation au bord de la
route un reportage de Raphaël Tondreau
Gautier et de Capucine colin-guy Auchan
pour la chaîne TVA regardez
ce sont les premiers du genre ces deux
panneaux de sensibilisation ont été
installés la semaine dernière sur cette
axe particulièrement fréquentée de brut
dans les deux sens de circulation à
l'origine l'idée vient d'Isabelle
Lemoine bénévole de l'association boulet
pics depuis 6 ans elle prend en charge
les hérissons blessés durant une
quinzaine de jours avant de les remettre
en liberté sur cette zone qui se trouve
à proximité de la route j'ai constaté
que des hérissons se faisaient écraser
devant chez moi si sans l'espace de 15
jours je me suis dit qu'il y avait un
intérêt en fait à peut-être installer
des panneaux la mairie lui a accordé
sortie d'hibernation au début du
printemps le hérisson n'a jamais été
aussi vulnérable dans son centre de
soins à proximité de Rennes Claude
recueille les animaux les plus abîmés il
est le seul à gré en Ille-et-Vilaine
il a perdu ses piquants l'animal ne peut
donc plus se protéger il faut attendre
que ces pics reviennent avant un retour
à la vie sauvage même
de bien s'acclimater
au régime dans ces cages une vingtaine
de petits la plupart est orphelin tous
trop jeunes pour l'extérieur voiture
jardinage claustra ces risques sont de
plus en plus présents dans la vie de ses
animaux je crois que
les soigner c'est devenu une vocation
pour Claude depuis une dizaine d'années
cet ancien bénévole de la Ligue de
Protection des Oiseaux est partie d'un
constat j'étais
surprisons or dans les centres de soins
en mammifères c'est le mammifère qu'on
reçoit le plus donc il y avait il y
avait un besoin
une passion qui lui a permis de sauver
90 hérissons cette année pour ce petit
c'est bientôt la fin des soins sur sa
pâte abîmée
mais il faut encore un peu de patience
avant de retrouver sa liberté
voilà et prudence donc lorsque vous
roulez à deux ou à 4 roues
automobile encore dans ce journal venir
entretenir sa voiture ou sa moto pour le
plaisir c'est le concept original du
méca club récemment installé dans le Val
d'Oise et passionnés de mécaniques
peuvent ainsi venir utiliser les 1300
mètres carrés d'atelier comme une salle
de sport grâce à une formule
d'abonnement cet enseigne unique en
France a déjà fait plus de 200 adeptes
les détails avec la rédaction de via 95
regardez
être abonné à un club de mécanique comme
à une salle de sport c'est le concept
unique en France du méca club avec ses
15 box tout équipé installé dans un
atelier géant de 1300 mètres carrés les
passionnés de mécaniques peuvent venir
entretenir leur voiture ou leur moto
toute l'année vous prenez un abonnement
vous avez accès à une partie de
l'atelier en illimité du mardi au
dimanche de 10h à 20h donc tout ce qui
est machine à pneus équilibreuse bande
géométrie valise diagnostic espace de
travail partagé ça c'est limité et puis
avec les heures de pont qui sont soumis
organisation et donc pour ça on a
différentes formules avec plus ou moins
d'heures de points à consommer dans
l'année et ça permet de répondre à tous
types de projets que ce soit de des
petites réparations des grosses
réparations de la restauration de
véhicules la préparation de véhicules
pour le circuit voilà on est capable de
tout faire pour moins de 30 euros par
mois pour une voiture et 20 euros pour
une moto le meca club et surtout un lieu
d'échange et de partage autour de la
mécanique destinée à tous les passionnés
quel que soit leur niveau 90% de nos
clients c'est des novices pour la
plupart ils ont même jamais encore monté
un véhicule sur un pont donc on leur
apprend à mettre déjà un véhicule sur un
pont en sécurité et ensuite de faire des
vidanges des plaquettes l'autre niveau
c'est les pneus la géométrie et puis on
avance comme ça step by step comme dans
une salle de sport on a des coachs donc
ils sont 4 et du coup ça permet de les
accompagner dans tout ce qui est ensuite
distribution voilà embrayage voilà le
but c'est il suffit d'avoir l'envie et
ensuite c'est du temps de la patience et
puis du plaisir en fin de compte tout
simplement venir au Méka club pour le
plaisir c'est le cas de Thierry un
ancien mécanicien auto tout le monde se
donne un petit peu des ficelles sur le
on connaît pas spécialement toutes les
voitures par coeur donc il y a toujours
des gens qui ont rencontré des galères
et qui connaissent quoi donc tout le
monde s'échange et puis quand on voilà
on fait depuis des petits repas de temps
en temps entre nous voilà c'est sympa
avec plus de 200 membres ici à
Saint-Ouen-l'Aumône le concept de self
garage connecté est en plein boom
Anthony souhaite lancer de nouveaux
projets de meca club dans le sud
francilien et à Bordeaux
voilà et ce seront c'est certain des
lectures attentifs d'auto plus cette
année le magazine fête ses 35 ans
l’hebdomadaire reconnu pour la fiabilité
de ces tests auto et de son impertinence
lance cet été une série qui sera très
utile pour ceux qui vont prendre la
route des vacances un sujet anniversaire
au fond de Christophe frigo regardez
35 ans c'est l'âge de la maturité pour
le magazine Auto Plus depuis 1988
l'hebdo bien connu des automobilistes
s'est fait une place dans le monde de la
presse auto la recette du succès d'auto
plus se mettre à la place du conducteur
il y a pas longtemps une des grandes
questions quand il y a eu la flambée des
prises et de savoir si on pouvait mettre
de l'eau 85 en mettre plus en mettre
moins faut sentir le poulet automobile
il faut être automobiliste pour ça tout
simplement et puis l'avantage c'est que
nous on va se poser la question lambda
on va pas forcément la réponse mais on a
les outils pour pour le savoir on a le
temps pour chercher donc on va se poser
les mêmes questions que tout le monde et
on va chercher à avoir des réponses
pratiques on a des spécialistes pour ça
on a des instruments de mesure pour ça
je vais pouvoir mettre de répondre à
toutes les questions vous pouvez vous
poser même les plus bêtes et c'est
important l'autre spécialité d'auto plus
ce sont les essais réaliser chaque
semaine par le labo du magazine installé
à Montlhéry 400 voitures sont testées
chaque année par un expert maison si
vous fiez un constructeur non seulement
les chiffres seront
mais le problème aussi c'est que vous
savez pas à quel point ils seront
embellis donc ils sont très durs à
comparer entre les noces sont évidemment
comparables entre eux puisqu'on a des
protocoles de test qui sont toujours le
même il y a une vraie approche
scientifique par rapport à ça l'idée
c'est d'être un outil pour l'automobile
pour qu'ils puissent faire son choix que
ce soit en neuf ou en occasionner
toujours plus près des automobilistes
l'hebdo lance cet été une grande série
pour trouver tous les bons plans pour
bien manger sur la route des vacances
aux abords des autoroutes une bonne
raison pour vous rendre dans le kiosque
le plus proche avant de prendre la route
voilà il vit avec sa femme et ses quatre
enfants dans un cimetière depuis 2018
Benoît Gallo et le conservateur du
cimetière le plus connu au monde celui
du Père Lachaise à Paris un métier
original fait de silence qu'il raconte
notamment dans son livre La vie secrète
d'un cimetière et aussi sur son compte
Instagram la rédaction de 20 minutes TV
a voulu en savoir un peu plus et s'est
rendu à ça en compte propos recueilli
par Thomas Barito depuis 2018 je suis
conservateur du cimetière du
Père-Lachaise l'émission consiste de
gérer le personnel qui travaille plus de
80 personnes veillent à l'entretien du
cimetière et à l'accueil des usagers et
moi en particulier ma tâche c'est de
reprendre des concessions à l'abandon et
de délivrer de nouvelles concessions
funéraires à des familles le cimetière
du Père-Lachaise est le plus grand
espace vert intra-muros de Paris il
occupe une surface de 43 hectares au
total il y a 70
000 tombes et 26000 cases de colombarion
mais on évalue à un million 300000 le
nombre de défunts qui repose au Père la
chaise
voilà et si vous désirez en découvrir un
peu plus sur la vie du cimetière
parisien vous pouvez suivre le compte
Instagram de Benoît Gallo la vie au
cimetière sans transition dans ce
journal partons désormais en Moselle
pour faire la rencontre d'Alex et de Rio
le premier est un jeune garçon sourd le
second un chien fidèle et compagnon de
vie axel est le seul enfant atteint de
surdité en France à bénéficier de ce
dispositif que ce soit à l'école dans la
rue ou à la maison les deux sont devenus
inséparables comme a pu le constater
lucifilippo pour Moselle TV
lui c'est Axel et lui Rio inséparable
ils suivent un cours de mathématiques
sourd de naissance accès à le droit
d'être accompagné par son ami à quatre
pattes depuis le 4 mai ce berger
australien se joint à son jeune maître
quelques heures par semaine à l'Institut
des Jeunes Sourds de Metz une adaptation
plutôt bien perçue par la direction de
l'établissement partout tout le temps
Rio facilite la vie d'Axel et lui permet
de créer plus aisément du lien social
avec ses camarades avant il se mettait à
table à jouer aux échecs avec un
éducateur et là depuis que Rio est
arrivé ils sont tous ensemble ils sont
groupés alors ils viennent voir le chien
une petite caresse de temps en temps
même s'ils ont pas le droit et et Axel
est entouré d'amis maintenant entrez
dans la vie de la famille il y a six
mois Rio et ce qu'on appelle un chien
écouteurs il accompagne tous les
déplacements du jeune homme de 14 ans et
ses réactions servent aussi à avertir
Axel en cas d'imprévu ou de danger pour
cela Rio doit rester concentré ré alors
lorsqu'il porte son harnais interdiction
de le caresser il travaille
dans la rue dès qu'il y a un bruit dès
qu'il y a un danger il vient se coller à
son maître pour lui signaler qu'il y a
un danger qui a un véhicule qui vient
une trottinette une voiture et quand il
est en intérieur il va réagir à la
sonnette le téléphone qui sonne si on
appelle Axel il va aller le chercher en
France axel est le premier jeune sourd à
bénéficier d'un compagnon à quatre
pattes issus de l'association grâce à la
qualité de la formation reçue Rio a même
été décoré du titre de chien héros à
Paris par la centrale canine chaque jour
sa présence permet d'améliorer le
quotidien de la famille Axel Dormans
avec son animal de compagnie avec son
compagnon nous ça nous soulage on peut
dormir on n'est pas obligé de
l'accompagner au lit de dormir avec lui
comme il faisait avant parce qu'il avait
des terrains en nocturne là quand il va
se réveiller il va appeler son chien il
va monter sur le lit avec lui il va le
prendre dans ses bras il va se rendre au
milieu instantanément Rio travaillera
aux côtés d'accès jusqu'à l'âge de 10
ans âge légal de sa retraite enfin si
l'âge de la retraite canine n'est pas
reporté d'ici là
une belle histoire pour accélérer Rio
qui nous conduit désormais dans
l'Hérault où était organisé il y a
quelques jours vous le voyez à l'image
une visite viticole inclusive pour sourd
et malentendant une balade rendue
possible évidemment grâce à la présence
d'un interprète et en langue des signes
images et explications récoltées par
Justine barreau pour viaxtany en tant
qu'interprète on entend ce qui est dit
en langue française on le déverbalise
c'est à dire qu'on retient simplement le
sens qui qui est dit en français et on
va le traduire dans une autre langue
dans la langue des signes françaises et
parfois forcément il y a des signes
qu'on a pas et des mots qu'on qui n'ont
pas leur équivalent en langue des signes
et donc on est un petit peu obligé de
soit le traduire avec une périphrase
soit le les peler tout simplement
allez restons au soleil dans les vignes
dans ce journal pour découvrir une
tendance qui n'en est presque plus une
tantelle se confirme chaque année à
l'heure de l'été le succès du rosé et
sans partage sur les autres vins une
réalité à laquelle n'échappe pas les
vignerons bordelais exemple dans la
coopérative tu tiaques qui a anticipé le
phénomène depuis une dizaine d'années
désormais la moitié de la production est
consacrée au vin frais un pari payant
puisque les bouteilles bordelaise
rivalisent avec les rosés de Provence et
des tailles d'Yves branchis pour TV 7 la
chaîne du groupe sud-ouest
le millésime de 2023 est prometteur
quand on voit la sortie de vendanges qui
peut y avoir espérons que voilà que tous
ces raisins deviennent bien rouges du
raisin beaucoup de raisins c'est l'un
des secrets de sa réussite au niveau de
la taille on va augmenter un petit peu
le nombre de boutons pour avoir un petit
peu plus de quantité parce que pour
faire du rosé on a besoin de plus de jus
ça permettra d'avoir plus de raisin sur
sur la vente sur la vigne 5400 hectares
de vignes que les 500 vignerons de cette
coopérative surveillent de très près
pour produire leurs rosés donc on
incorpore l'avantage dans les pressoires
on presse et ça ça permet d'extraire des
arômes qu'on a peut-être pas forcément
justement quand on fait des des rosés de
macération en cuve cette technique
similaire aux roses et provençale s'est
affiné au fil du temps car ici on
produit du vin de toutes les couleurs
depuis bientôt 50 ans mais aujourd'hui
c'est le vin frais et surtout le rosé
qui a la côte sur les 10 dernières
multiplié par 10 le nombre de colles et
aujourd'hui on arrive à enfin 46 les
taux de production une réussite
commerciale devenue il y a quelques
semaines consécration nationale lors
d'une dégustation à l'aveugle organisée
par la Revue du vin de France ils ont
été relativement surpris parce qu'en
fait dans le top 5 un Bordeaux rosé est
apparu et donc au milieu de rosé qui se
vendent à peu près une vingtaine d'euros
et bien rosé de Bordeaux qui au moins de
6 euros sur les 28 bouteilles dégustées
trois autres rosés Bordelais ont été
plébiscitées dont un qui finit execo
avec le rosé Miraval le célèbre domaine
de l'acteur Brad Pitt alors pour le 50e
anniversaire des vignerons de Tutiac
l'invitation est lancée
allez du rosé aux roses on referme cette
édition à la découverte d'un métier
aussi passionnant que méconnu celui
d'obtenteur de rose une profession
parfumée qui réclame patience et
croisement et que nous fait découvrir
Lina Brady pour Télé Grenoble regardez
elles ont vécu leur plus belle robe
c'est leur façon à elle de piquer notre
curiosité mais avant cela il faut les
faire naître au grand lynx la Roseraie
Félix donne la vie aux roses en les
accouplant donc j'enlève les pétales hop
comme ça et après le principe c'est
d'enlever tous les pollens qui se
trouvent
autour des pistils c'est un travail très
minutieux canis doit réaliser de fleurs
en fleurs voilà donc là il reste plus
que le pistil et après on vient mettre
du pollen du nain d'un autre rosier sur
ce pistil et après il y a un nouveau
fruit et il faut que le fruit vienne à
maturité pour
pour faire des graines et là on met bien
une étiquette avec un numéro pour se
rappeler de quelle combinaison c'est
pour savoir le père et la mère
chaque combinaison est réfléchie à
partir de deux fleurs avec des
caractères intéressants car
l'hybridation est complexe et
imprévisible c'est pas parce que la
maman est rouge et le papa est rouge
qu'on va avoir des bébés rouges
obtenteur de rose est un métier rare et
un métier d'art ici ils effectuent 3000
croisements chaque année pour finalement
ne garder qu'une seule variété et il
faut 8 ans entre la fécondation et la
sélection
ultime pour voir peut-être un jour
éclore la rose de ses rêves mon Graal
depuis j'ai commencé en 2006 c'est de
trouver une rose orange à grande fleur
parfumées qui qui soit suffisamment
résistante pour qu'on puisse l'utiliser
dans le paysage ou dans les jardins
d'amateurs mais sont sans s'en occuper
sans sans beaucoup la tailler et surtout
sans la traiter puisque un rosier doit
pouvoir pousser tout seul et en
attendant de voir ses rêves fleurir la
Roseraie Félix continuera devrait en
toute humilité car soumise aux lois de
la nature
c'est la fin de cette édition merci
d'avoir suivi le grand JT des
territoires on se retrouve très vite
pour une prochaine édition en vrai à
tous
[Musique]